[Musique]
voilà voilà voilà voilà
sur ce bateau douze mois sur douze
depuis 25 ans gérard borg est un homme
heureux sur terre à bord des caravanes
qu'il découvre il veut tout essayé on ne
sait jamais
dans le capitaine on n'est pas aux îles
marquises la non mais on est d'après mes
calculs pas loin de fontainebleau
oui alors un sextant bah écoutez d'abord
je ne sais pas jusqu'où nous irons dans
votre expérience
alors soyons prudents on savait que
toutes les caravanes se dirigent vers la
mer c'est bien connu comme les rivières
alors j'ai apporté mon petit matériel et
donc vous saviez borg vous au fond de
votre bateau qui a en france près de 3
millions de caravaniers autant que deux
plaisanciers à peu près ouais ouais
alors on va vous faire faire
l'expérience donc on essaie de voir un
de plus
oh la la misère vous croyez que c'est
bien utile va on va bien voir
alors autant de l'expérience je trouve
bien courageux monsieur déplace matin
oui bah vous aussi on voit est un métier
monsieur quand vous m'avez dit trois
millions et demi de français qui
s'amusent à ça je n'ai pas très bien
compris souvenance sur la côte d'azur
cet amalgame cette espèce de monstre
villages aux villes qui se forme chaque
année au mois d'août
elle paraît aberrant mais ici par
exemple dans cette forêt de
fontainebleau
beh compte
voilà des images d'une autre france de
celle qui vaut le détour et qu'avec sa
caravane en lui abandonne ses week-ends
et ses vacances le ruisseau n'est pas la
mer mais son nom est plus pur
ici pas de camping surpeuplé car la
campagne ça se déguste des 2000 modèle
présenté au dernier salon la plupart
proposait des aménagements intérieurs de
plus en plus sophistiqués nouveautés ou
presque
l'isolation thermique et le chauffage
grâce auquel le caravaneige n'est plus
un problème
les prix ils tiennent le choc une
caravane classique pour 4 personnes vaut
cette année en moyenne seize mille
francs cette année encore un grand boum
les caravane pliante
j'avoue ça monsieur aïe c'est une
cliente une pliante
qu'est ce que vous mettez là dedans
c'est une caravane c'est pour les tout
petits c'est pour les tout petits sur la
route et ou grands à l'étape vous fait
voir ah oui aller à huy
[Musique]
oui
alors que movie dont quand ça se passe
est ce qu'il y a par exemple une cuisine
je soupçonne qu'il est loin de cuisine
par ici mais c'est le carré d'un bateau
bien équipée 1 c'est-à-dire une cuisine
avec un réfrigérateur avec montrer
montrer montrer un peu ce secteur mais
il est bien avec un plan inox et danse à
maffle sur quoi sur batterie ça marche
sur batterie ça marche sur gaz
c'est un but commun dit rien c'est à
dire trois sources d'énergie sur la
voiture sur le secteur et sur le gaz sur
lequel un certain nombre de petits
gadgets autre histoire bien sûr qui font
que la ménagère trouvent les son
rangement le placard de pavillons ya
vingt ans comme on retrouve dans une
caravane pliante
c'est plus limité dans les rangements oh
bien sûr il faut pas oublier aussi qu'on
est dans une 3 mètres et que très
sincèrement je crois qu'une fois déployé
c'est véritablement une caravane
classique jusqu'à jusqu'à une belle
banderilles lapandry qui est tout à fait
classique on n'imagine pas du tout parce
que la caravane et pied effectivement on
peut y mettre je crois facilement 4
europe
et quant au couchage ici vous avez 132
large sur 2 mètres de long c'est à dire
un bon lit classiques comme à la maison
et puis les enfants peuvent trouver
place à l'avant avec une autre couche
est qui fait 60 ou 70 selon les modèles
et puis on peut encore mettre une autre
couchettes superposées
ce qui fait que dans une caravane comme
celle ci on compte quatre personnes très
facilement capitaine au bout ça va c'est
une bonne sieste on dort bien bas pas
mal c'est plus tard que le bateau
ah oui ah oui c'est bien avec joie que
vous embêtez pas alors premières
découvertes caravane et ben ça va c
c'est du bateau sans roulis labeur avec
des roues et sans voile sans marée sans
porc dire qu'évidemment
l'immensité de la mer est réduite à
ruban d'
d'asphalt mais d'un autre côté les ports
sont partout ont mûri n'importe où ça
c'est quand même un autre commandant
première question
j'ai un permis de conduire de monsieur
tout le monde veut passer en 1946 est-ce
que je peux produire cet attelage cet
ensemble
oui vous avez un permis de conduire de
la catégorie b vous avez donc
possibilité l'autorisation de piloter
cet ensemble composé d'un véhicule
tracteur et d'une remorque
tout simplement parce que en règle
générale le poids total autorisé en
charge de la remorque ne doit pas
dépasser le poids à vide du véhicule
tracteur mais c'est beaucoup plus
complexe que ça on est courageux dans
les crs on est courageux vont
m'accompagner
je vous accompagne en route
alors deux cas dans le cas actuel votre
permis b catégorie comme tout le monde
vous dit
et donc suffisant mais si le poids total
en charge de votre caravane est
supérieur à 750 kg 750000 750 kg m et
alors là qu'est ce qu'il faut obtenir un
permis
oui alors l'obtention de ce permis un
qui est délivré à tous les titulaires du
permis b devrait permis dont c'est une
extension ses dimensions - vous et
délivrer ce permis e sur présentation
d'un certificat médical favorable
délivré par la commission médicale placé
auprès du préfet il n'y a pas de
d'autres permis à passer d'autres et pas
du tout avant tout simplement
et alors j'apporte quand même une
précision c'est que les titulaires des
permis
cc 1 et dès qu'ils sont les permis poids
lourds en commun le permis e est
accordée par équivalent
et puis ne pas oublier d'adapter la
distance de freinage au poids et à la
longueur de l'ensemble tracts et les
rétroviseurs spéciaux obligatoires sur
les ailes avant ne pas oublier enfin que
avec une caravane certaines manoeuvres
deviennent délicates pour leur
commandant nous allons faire et va nous
allons donner dans l'abomination de
refaire une marcheurs ayant essayé d'en
faire une vraie voir comment se
présenteront pas que votre remorque vous
échappe ce soit la côte est soit de nos
cabas c'est ce qu'elle est en train de
flers saynètes elle et antoine se
balader non alors là c'est un échec
total
alors on va donc reprendre ça ça y est
non elle m'échappe
non non non rien à faire vous dites donc
c'est c'est pas tellement c'est votre
histoire
bon
[Musique]
les copines car plus cher que les
caravanes c'est vrai pour deux raisons
d'abord plus besoin de voiture ensuite
la tva 33 % contre 17 60 pour les
caravanes le prix moyen pour quatre
personnes
quatre-vingt mille francs avec les
pliante les copines car c'est le grand
boum synonyme de confort et de liberté
et puis c'est le do it yourself et
l'aménagement d'une camionnette
utilitaire encore pincar grâce à une
cellule en kit démontable enfin avec un
camping car on peut passer sa nuit
partout même aux champs elysées ça c'est
un autre genre d'engin gérard bord que
le camping car vous savez que ya
beaucoup beaucoup de propriétaires de
camping cars qui avait avant un bateau
ça retourne à un bateau un petit peu non
je vous dirais que celle même le bateaux
hauturiers c'est quand même c'est quand
même autre chose c'est plus lourd c'est
plus gros et puis c'est une pièce la
conduite des différentes ça vous plaît
d'une pièce mieux avec les autres
formules j'ai l'impression d'être un
moteur qui remorque un bateau alors que
là je suis dans le bateau d'un dépôt
différents
[Musique]
c'est un peu bruyant non au nom c'est un
truc viril ça ça me plaît et voyez c'est
vraiment un truc costaud c'est autre
nouveauté est reconnu par le ministère
de l'équipement les parcs résidentiels
vaste résidence divisé en lotissement de
plus de 200 mètres carrés
c'est la nature en direct pour pas très
cher tout compris moins de 500 francs
par mois des parcs résidentiels comme
celui d'artemis présenté mme blot il en
existe déjà près de 1000 répartis autour
des villes sur l'ensemble du territoire
ici encore pas de surpeuplement et rien
ne manque au gaz l'électricité et même
le tout l ai dit comment appelle-t-on ça
un mobile home à ce point car avant non
c'est un mobile-home un mobile home
alors donc ça se sache ce tract s'amène
sur un sur une plate forme comment
est-ce qu'on s'assoit en général où il
sait des convois spéciaux combat
exceptionnel et mais où sommes-nous ici
c'est un terrain en location et qui nous
convient très bien
alors c'est un c'est un grand terrain
dont la forêt et y est louée par
parcelle marcel et jeannine zèle oui
chacun a sa parcelle et le mobil-home
être installé dessus
chacun sa petite pelouse son petit
terrain où il fait des petits des fleurs
c'est un agrément très plaisant mais
alors tous les week-ends vous venez tous
les week-ends où on arrive le samedi à
midi on reparle dimanche soir ou lundi
matin et toutes les vacances scolaires
sont passés ici et vos gosses mumuse
avec nos enfants
dans le forez les petites bêtes et tout
ira bien aucun danger puisque c'est
foutu y'a pas de voiture dans le camp
c'est tout ce que j'ai vu tout à l'heure
le restaurant la piscine tout ça c'est
dans le même goût tout ça c'est un même
groupe s est compris dans le prix de la
location alors parlons de prix bon vous
avez là un un mobile home qui est tout
de même assez important sa mesure
combien 9 mètres de long sur 30 mètres
de large
vous avez là dedans je présume alors un
coin cuisine la salle à manger
vous n'avez pas de salle de bain quand
même c'est il ya une salle de bain avec
une baignoire et les wcg a évidemment
c'est quand même très grand et points de
vue quand vous avez votre chance
on a une chambre avec un grand lit de
personnes et les enfants cent quarante
de large
il ya deux couchettes pour les enfants
dans une autre petite sociologie petites
pièces sont alors le mobile est un salon
vous a coûté combien 43 mille francs à
l'achat il y a trois ans aujourd'hui ça
vaudrait combien entre 50 et 55 bonds
investissent le même modèle
investissements 50000 pour le même
modèle bien ri
ça vous coûte combien par an la
jouissance du terrain et de tout ce qui
tourne l'an dernier nous est revenu tout
compris aux environs de 6000 francs
reste pour les fanas où les
indécrottables la possibilité de la
télévision sur place et pour tous le
soleil énergie idéal pour recharger les
batteries ou retrouver son tonus et même
pour ce faire cuire à 9
le temps d'un week end bon eh bien il me
reste à vous dire au revoir à tous j'ai
passé une journée merveilleuse j'ai
appris beaucoup de choses
j'ai recherché de documentation pour
vous vous avez trouvé
alors il existe alors que en bateau il y
a six ou sept
revue tout cas quatre importantes ici
j'aurais trouvé deux alors le caravanier
et caravaning et camping cars et je
crois avoir trouvé à peu près toutes les
informations que je pouvais désir et que
vous désirez vous même
je crois que c'est assez complet c'est
bien fait et ça répond à peu près tous
les problèmes que peuvent se poser de
ceux qui désirent faire comme je vais
faire maintenant c'est à dire vous dire
au revoir et partir jusqu'au littoral et
même nous allons même aller jusqu'au
sardaigne pour retrouver mon bateau et
ce sera je crois une expérience très
confiant
[Musique]